Oh my god, today is
A big day
You saw the video I did recently
Where I said I waited 4 years to play this
'The Last Guardian' is finally out
so many didn't think it was actually going to happen
I think it almost got cancelled for a long time
but the fans are such hardcore fans
of this, this type of game since 'Shadow of Colossus'
That they brought it out and
just please. if you are watching this and at any point feel like you're excited about checking this game out
Don't hesitate, support- support games like this
I imagine it's harder for games that try to be more artsy and creative
to really be more commercial.
Rather than that last 'Call of Duty' or that last 'Final Fantasy'
Which I'm sure are great games, but it would be cool to see more of this.
And I would, I would love if my video can help support
support the games like this.
PlayStation sent one of these awesome things, just so I can brag a little bit.
So it has the fea- Jesus...
So it has the feathers right? But when you open it, watch this.
Last Guardian!
And it, it's like a little 3-D thing.
Okay, very cool.
The game,
and a little
feather.
*laughs*
And
I think it says,
this is copy 123 out of 2456.
There's only 2500 of these which
is not...I guess not that only?
But I wouldn't be surprised if this sold for a lot on eBay, let's just say that.
So I really appreciate
that PlayStation sent me one of these.
NOW, w- fuck that, okay?
Let's just get into the game.
Whoo! This is gonna be an epic, epic series,
Please do leave a like to support the first episode, it really means a lot.
And, let's get into this. It's gonna be a daily, daily show.
Ah, why not just get started right away?
And it does get started right away, what is this?
What am I looking at, I didn't give it a much thought.
It's a, it's a ground.
That's a sentence.
It's a ground! It's a floor!
It's a kids!
I'm, I'm not getting a sense of scale here, what are we- oh okay.
*children giggling*
What is happening?
That's our hero.
Beautiful.
The Last Guardian.
In case you can't read.
What does that mean then?
'Fumito Ueda' I probably butchered that name.
In a world...
wheres bees, oh and my God bees!
It's very cool so far. *chuckles*
Got cool birds and shit, got bats with little feet, that's cute.
And a bellybutton.
And dogs, with beard. That's cool.
And we got cat-dogs.
And goat-goats. Man goats are so creepy look at them.
That looks like a pillow.
That's a, that's a unicorn. *laughs*
In a world,
where mystical beasts lives. That's a gryffin isn't it? Gryffis.
Wow, look at that, that's cool.
Got gloves and shit.
Is that a phoenix?
It is.
And then we have Trico.
So that's it's name maybe? Trico?
The rarest of them all.
Designed and directed by Fumito Ueda.
Cool.
So I remember this. When I died,
I had to like. You have to click to get those away.
Took me a long time to figure it out.
When it first happened I'm like "What the fuck is this?"
But
Am I moving the chains? No I'm not.
Oh there, there's Trico.
He looks hurt!
Remember Abro from Shadow of the Colossus, the horse?
The chosen ones...
clean up
Flying through the darkness...
And now we move.
We wake up.
So... we're already old and we're telling the story from our childhood.
*child coughs* Alright, let's wake up.
Very, interesting way of story telling.
*child screams* And there's Trico!
And we seem, pretty shocked by Trico, what?
Alright let's go up again.
you need you
united talk to other Tudor boy cool is a
Man-eating beast...
And the tattoos I guess?
Are new?
under me
I mean, you must be pretty drunk if you wake up with that many tattoos you know?
Well at least he didn't wake up with a tribal you know?
*trico squeals*
*kid is shocked*
Trico, oh my God, what happened?
*trico growls*
Okay
OK
No thanks!
So we woke up here and we don't know what happened.
I don't think Trico trusts us yet.
Okay, so we're sneaking~
Nope, we're not .-.
Can I help you Trico? ;-;
Lemme-
Look, that looks painful. Lemme pull that out.
Let me help you with that.
*very heartwarming*
Easy boy...
Easy...
Easy Trico...
I'm try- ahh
I'm not try'na 'trico' you *nice try poods*
I'm sorry, em sorry.
Okay, I'm on 'em.
Remove the spear.
*struggling*
Argh-
This is like, reverse Shadow of Colossus.
There it is...
OHHH GEEZ OW
AHHH FUCKK!
*poor kid in agony* *wtf trico*
Well, that'll do it
*laughs*
n- No we didn't die, did we?
Thanks Trico~ :3
*kid still passed out D:*
Okay...
*kid's regaining consciousness*
We're waking up, again?
We're not feeling to well, but I hope Trico is, Jesus Christ.
now tell that to all you can walk now
nevermind 90210 just to get all three
cool hungry for something I'll never go
up there there's one of these I remember
you feed them to them to jump with this
one
ok now how do I hold myself up okay pick
up the barrel you hungry buddy now
that's cool i love the animation so for
so pretty look at all right now we're
gonna throw it was able to nail that
nail the Treecko good job
I'm trying to help you here you know
what you wanted a spoon feed you
okay sorry sorry you want it or not
forget 22 cool and overcome easy you
trust me
other two are you just eating you know
you just the to see but dude that's like
a lot of them what we got here then it's
interesting how their the storytelling
is helping out of progress i really like
that
alright well dude i got like how much do
you need buddy i'm feeling a cocaine
what is this drugs
this is like catnip for some shit area
go
you're fucking welcome by the way you
want more fine help nail that i love how
you toss that it's awesome i'm still
kind of learning the controls
it's a bit weird alright where is it
oye one
okay you're feeling better now that you
got your butterfly Jews body you want
some out
now you go your fuck shut up
eat it that's it I'm out
maybe he only you can't see me if you're
gonna he does huh
it's just like a get-well up
Oh need another one
it really is amazing how they did the
little beast because it really feels
like at all
it feels dumb just like my own pet you
know cuz you know I'm here
are you happy now you trust me as his
knees if we approach him
hey road
alright i'm down by day
fine you know I don't want to be here
anyway
22 cool and overcome easy to do are two
other do audio dusty to kick you notice
you toss the 2z auto do we do your
daughter hostage
I don't what we want to anymore but
there's food more there you're stupid
it doesn't see us now just eat okay here
we go
stupid Treecko mark mark
there you go you happy now surprised it
was me all along i am the hand that fed
you you should be happy
thanks for kick come on dude come on
Trey Cal you got a trick up t.o.o see
also you can you go you're looking like
to go to do 60 of them
ok so the most senior to get I'll help
you with this chain and secure
hey buddy i can come near it now so i
think i'm gonna have to go up here take
it easy buddy
do not kick me you do-si-do do-si-do
other spirits right shoulder employees
cruces easy to acquire and CN
here we go
the spirit this is gonna sting a little
bit not kick me again
pop why do you keep doing that
really man
great
what a great start
we really truly did it we took three
naps now you're now you're happy now you
like me
ok alright morning breath
thank you doesn't smell very nice
all right we need to get you off this
chain dude I can call him now
yeah I did too yeti out how he's up and
running huh
ok so how why would I call him how he
follows but he can't go too far
is there anywhere i would like to go i
don't know let's try and get this chain
away I let's call up on I Treecko I'm
not trying to tickle your ass I'm just
trying to set you free all right here we
go
pulled a lever how convenient head that
that's better isn't it
oh why not grip him
where am I here we can all right
beautiful means this is so cool
he's shaking up the armor your free
Treecko you look a little naked but
that's okay I'm not gonna let go
we're gonna go so now we can direct him
where to go
which honestly I don't know where how
about up there
how about up there where we came from
congressman from ikea all this way cool
I don't know what you go here come on
trick oh come on by
cool man it's so pretty oh my God look
at this incredible
hey buddy hey look who came huh mr. fish
feet i'm going to climb tribute to get
up here
there we go are you stand still
it's going to be a lot to do not fart
right now man
ok just stay right okay you made the
bucket alright that's not what i wanted
to do and I'm kind of terrified
there we go that's what I totally what i
wanted to do you want some more juice
alright you want some of this you know i
have to eat too you know
oh I'm sorry and i think i can go in
here i can for well what the half
ok this is unexpected but we're doing it
we're going through
keep crawling hopefully there's no
snakes I'm super scared of snakes if
trigger was a snake
I don't know how much I would like this
game you know what I mean he's a bird
bird dog cat thing then yeah you know
it's cool all right hey how whoa cool
that light where r ji says I sort of
accidentally went in here i right
ok let's check this out
whoa it's like it's like an Egyptian
pickup thing i'll be taking this
whoa wow what what the hell illuminate
hold down and move Latin School of oh no
good second point this towards me you
know to go your holders too coz you're
too i decided to borrow and most great
alright whatever you will however you
want to tell this story are cool I can
equip it all right let's go back and
shine it somewhere where the Sun don't
shine
this is so cool I'm blown away by this
game so fire
ok where do we come from in here
yeah yeah yeah definitely i can just
manage to get into that
suspicious-looking whole everything we
have to under quick okay now I'm not
questioning the logic of that being a
part of my sweater but it's hovering ok
it's hot sides hovering have you ever
heard about that right isn't it faces
fucking blowing up
oh you had a good nap or lets up
what the hell oh he doesn't like it
oh yeah he gets scared of like ancient
tech dude your eyes are like fucking
holographs Jesus Christ with the final
do what kind of shit are you smoking
ok let's be careful using that right now
but let's find where then that the first
that third-person this is a little bit
like mario 64 like it's a lot of times
where you don't want it to be and I wish
I could go into first person mode a
little bit
this is kinda weird ok let's go down ok
what if we use it
well well well what that is happening a
tuna can be Chuck also boy all totally
cool
always oh yeah then you talk to you can
shit fucking lightning you withhold more
open to cool your world is this
that's a surprise okay well he's done
here so i guess we are as well if we can
shoot frickin lightning imagine that
unlimited they can eat
ok so what if we shoot the unlimited
lightning and work here
wow that's cool man
dude we're gonna have so much fun ok i'm
sure there's somewhere we can actually
use it like here that would make sense
right
yeah yeah what's after the giant stones
alright trickled let's let's go we go
hey whole well hey letting our shared
like this paper at me
yeah 3 all of them are comedies on your
cube it wz or Manny your total Stacy it
doesn't seem man-eating to me
oh my god this is one look at oh ok
nail that jump tonight
therefore now treecko you're a little
bigger than me don't know how to say
that in a polite way
oh ok we're going to have him shoot
lightning again it's time boy
it's like I got a living Tesla coil with
me fucking awesome dude I do not expect
this
this is cool alright well let's keep
going is she with me
are you with me Treecko is so cute
oh my god ok what whoa alright so ready
all it's all pretty
let's jump in well well then I just hit
the only piece of wood in the plug-in
water
ok so you've got stuff over here we've
got stuff over here let's swim over here
about trickers like scared of water
what a nerd
alright yeah I wanted to jump in trick
oh look at it but I don't like to take
baths
it looks like Edgar in a bathtub pretty
much all right yeah it's telling us
about it
well but a big butt bone
Thank You trigger it's been a pleasure
as always ok you wait there I'll be
right that back yet the of course- chain
that is how you climb chains everybody
it plays a lot smoother than when i
played it i think they fixed a lot of
the controls which is cool
maybe I'm saying that too soon
I don't know but it looks like a puzzler
I like possible i can dig it
alright we got a box with filled with
butterfly candy and we can grip by
holding them
okay you're pushing
now this is not really what I was your
really suck at pushing dude
and we can really now that streak out
there maybe we need to trick o to go in
the water yet these jokes are going to
get old real fast right now we're just
getting started as well there it is you
well it tickles my balls
yes Let Go button is next
alright let's get one a break though I
got your favorite candy you want some
butter flat drugs
well come get him
oh my god the border
and ok let's go get another one another
one and another one and three
I know you like the cane so I got you
one not that one
I don't think he needs more than that I
think that was he needs three let's jump
on top of them and driving
god damn you smell when you went ok now
where do we go are cool we can go here
it all makes sense thank you but man I'm
frame
oh my god hey hey buddy okay I don't
fall down for that
thank you too treecko oh my god is
shaking off like a wet dog
hey how you doing puts you're looking
real nice thank you for that butterfly
snack i really appreciate it
mi no problem hey what's over here more
snacks
I don't know Jesus Christ give me a sec
like I have to do everything
actually that's not sure we can shoot
lightning out of his ass
ok alright Treecko i'm going to be right
back
just whatever just come back with more
snakes please all so cute
oh my god I wish Edgar was actually cute
like that
whoa well well well what do we have here
beautiful absolutely beautiful waterfall
oh noes 0 take no chances leave him but
what
alright we're going to pause the first
episode right here we're going to start
off a little slower and then we're going
to keep up the pace so everyone can keep
up but this is really cool i'm really
really enjoying this and i would really
help if you guys join me on this
adventure leave a like if you enjoyed
and I'll see you tomorrow with the new
part and we can go through this thing
together i'm really excited i think it
will be a lot of fun it's been awhile
since we didn't play through this
channel so i hope you join me on this
and as always stay awesome bros